WELCOME TO THE SHOW
I KNOW BLACK PEOPLE,
WHERE WE TAKE CONTESTANTS
WHO CLAIM TO KNOW BLACK PEOPLE
AND PUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE
OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN CULTURE
TO THE TEST.
THE CONTESTANT WHO ANSWERS
THE MOST QUESTIONS, OF COURSE,
WINS OUR GRAND PRIZE.
LET'S BRING THEM OUT
ONE AT A TIME NOW.
OUR FIRST CONTESTANT
IS A PROFESSOR
OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN
STUDIES AND HISTORY
AT FORDHAM UNIVERSITY;
A NEW YORK CITY
POLICE OFFICER;
THIS IS A WRITER
FOR SUCH BLACK TELEVISION SHOWS
AS THE CHRIS ROCK SHOW
AND CHAPPELLE'S SHOW;
OKAY, OUR NEXT CONTESTANT WORKS
IN A KOREAN GROCERY STORE;
THIS IS A DJ AND CLAIMS
TO HAVE MANY BLACK FRIENDS;
A SOCIAL WORKER
IN WILMINGTON, DELAWARE;
MOST OF HIS BOYS HE GOES
TO SCHOOL WITH ARE BLACK;
THE BARBER IN BROOKLYN
WHO CLAIMS
THAT 100% OF HIS CLIENTS
ARE BLACK.
LET'S PLAY THE GAME.
WHAT IS A "BADONKADONK"?
A BADONKADONK.
A BADONKADONK
IS, LIKE, A, UH--
A INCREDIBLY ATTRACTIVE ASS.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
[whispers]
A BADONKADONK.
BIG PENIS.
buzz!
I DON'T KNOW.
HE'S TALKING
ABOUT MY REAR END, I THINK.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
[laughs]
YOU DO HAVE
A BADONKADONK.
I MAY HAVE HEARD THAT
ONCE OR TWICE BEFORE, YEAH.
I'M TELLIN' YOU,
WASHINGTON HEIGHTS,
THEY'LL TELL THE COPS,
"GIRL, YOU GOT
A BADONKADONK."
OOH, THAT'S JUNK
IN THE TRUNK.
THAT'S WHAT YOU PUT
YOUR MUG ON.
YOU SADDLE UP AND RIDE.
THAT'S A BIG...ASS.
ding!
HE IS CORRECT.
JUNK IN THE TRUNK...
ding!
WHAT YOU PUT YOUR MUG UP,
SADDLE UP AND RIDE,
OR AN ASS
ARE ALL ACCEPTABLE ANSWERS.
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
WHY DO BLACK PEOPLE
LOVE MENTHOLS SO MUCH?
I DON'T--I DON'T KNOW.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
[laughs]
ALL RIGHT.
NOBODY KNOWS.
NOBODY KNOWS FOR SURE.
'CAUSE THAT'S
WHAT NEWPORTS ARE?
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
IS IT A FACT THAT THEY LIKE
MENTHOL CIGARETTES?
I'M NOT EVEN SURE.
I DON'T KNOW--
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
"I DON'T KNOW."
NO ONE KNOWS.
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
ON THE POPULAR SHOW
GOOD TIMES,
WHAT DID MR. BOOKMAN DO
FOR A LIVING?
OOH, HE WAS THE HANDYMAN.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
HE WAS THE SUPER.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
LET'S SEE, I DON'T KNOW
WHO BOOKMAN WAS ON GOOD TIMES,
SO I'M GONNA HAVE
TO TAKE A GUESS.
UM...WAS HE A JANITOR?
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
AMAZING.
DID NOT KNOW SEE THE SHOW
YET KNOWS
THAT BOOKMAN
WAS CLEANING UP.
HE WAS THE JANITOR,
AND HIS NICKNAME
WAS BUFFALO BUTT.
THAT IS CORRECT
AND A BONUS POINT.
THANK YOU.
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
COULD YOU NAME
ANY OF BOOKMAN'S NICKNAMES?
BOOGER.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
BUFFALO BUTT.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
CHI-CHI?
I AM CHECKING THE JUDGES
FOR CHI-CHI.
buzz!
I'M SORRY, THAT'S INCORRECT.
HIS NAME WAS BOOKMAN?
YES, AND HE WAS FAT.
WHAT DID THEY CALL HIM?
UH, FAT JANITOR GUY.
buzz!
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
WHY DID BLACK PEOPLE
DISTRUST RONALD REAGAN?
BECAUSE HE WAS WHITE.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
BECAUSE HE WAS WHITE.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
WHY DID BLACK PEOPLE
DISTRUST RONALD REAGAN?
BECAUSE HE TOOK
ALL HIS MONEY.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
BECAUSE HE WAS
A REPUBLICAN.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
WHY DID BLACK PEOPLE
DISTRUST RONALD REAGAN?
HMM, HE WASN'T SUPPOSED TO BE
TRUSTED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
ding!
HE IS CORRECT.
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
TITO, IS PIMPING EASY?
NO.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
NO.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
BIG DADDY KANE WOULD SAY,
"IT AIN'T EASY."
"PIMPING AIN'T EASY,"
HE IS CORRECT.
IT'S HARD.
ding!
THAT IS CORRECT.
ALL RIGHT, I HAVE
A HARD TIME WITH IT MYSELF.
YES, PIMPING, AS A MATTER
OF FACT, AIN'T EASY.
IS PIMPING EASY?
HELL YEAH.
ding!
SOMEHOW THAT IS CORRECT.
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
WHOA, THE COMPETITION'S
HEATING UP.
BUT DON'T GO ANYWHERE,
BECAUSE WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH MORE I KNOW BLACK PEOPLE.
[cheers and applause]